It's not uncommon for creative people to find themselves stuck in a job...
...where they don't feel allowed to exercise their creativity.
But there's an old adage that applies here.
"It's often better to ask forgiveness than permission."
Do what you need to do and worry about the consequences later.
Pick one project at your job and work like the dickens...
...to do something creative, amazing and breathtaking.
And then see what happens.
If your boss freaks out, if people around you scorn you, if you get reprimanded...
...then you've learned something.
You're in a terrible job and you need to get out, now.
Life is too short to work at a place like that.
But if something else happens, as I suspect it might, if people say,...
..."Hey, good job!" or, "Wow! That was amazing."
Then you've also learned something important.
You've learned the place wasn't as bad as you thought.
You've learned more about your own capacities and, believe me,...
...you've begun to change the culture of your organization.
So give it a whirl. It's worth the risk.
Whatever happens, you're going to learn something important.